[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva edición de
áfrica siete días su magazine
informativo dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es malva norman y
estos son los titulares
solicitantes de asilo que piden refugio
en reino unido- serán enviados a ruanda
según un acuerdo firmado entre ambos
países
veremos cuáles son los intereses del
país africano en esta alianza en
sudáfrica históricas inundaciones
devastaron el este del país y miles de
habitantes se encuentran en total
desamparo analizaremos la situación con
omer freixá historiador africanista en
el este de la república democrática del
congo el conflicto armado que ya lleva
décadas se ha cobrado muchas vidas
humanas pero los animales tampoco se
libran de la violencia los llevaremos al
único refugio para grandes niños de la
zona
tras meses de negociaciones el jueves 14
de abril el gobierno del primer ministro
británico boris johnson anunció la firma
de un acuerdo con ruanda para enviar a
este país a solicitantes de asilo que
crucen el canal de la mancha con la
esperanza de encontrar refugio en reino
unido- se trata de una decisión inédita
en europa que organizaciones defensoras
de derechos humanos califican de cruel y
mexicas los solicitantes de asilo serán
alojados a 6400 kilómetros de londres en
ruanda donde se examinarán sus
solicitudes y en el mejor de los casos
si se les conceda el estatus de
refugiado será para residir en el
territorio ruandés y no para volver a
reino unido la política ha suscitado
fuertes críticas contra el ejecutivo de
boris johnson veamos en el siguiente
informe que intereses del país africano
se ponen en juego en esta alianza
y avanzar en el desarrollo del país ese
es el argumento formulado por las
autoridades ruandesas para justificar la
firma con el reino unido- de un pacto
controvertido sobre emigración aunque
este país africano de unos 13 millones
de habitantes ya acoge a más de 130 mil
refugiados principalmente de la
república democrática del congo y de
burundi su gobierno dice que está
dispuesto a acoger a varios miles de
inmigrantes devueltos desde el reino
unido y
estamos encantados de colaborar con el
reino unido en el marco de este acuerdo
va a dar el ok inc vale lo que de ubicar
a los migrantes en ruanda no sólo les
ayudará a ellos sino que beneficiará a
ruanda y a los ruandeses one dance el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
se ha comprometido a invertir 157
millones de dólares para ayudar a poner
en marcha el proyecto pero también para
apoyar el desarrollo del país donde el
40 por ciento de la población aún vive
por debajo del umbral de la pobreza pero
en un contexto en el que el crecimiento
económico se ha visto afectado por la
pandemia de kobe 19 y la inflación se ha
agravado por las consecuencias de la
guerra en ucrania
fue criticado por los opositores al
presidente ruandés paul kagamé
el partido verde democrático de ruanda
apoya la acogida de los refugiados que
han elegido a ruanda como primer destino
pensamos que los países ricos incluido
el reino unido- no deberían cambiar su
obligación internacional de acoger a los
refugiados y trasladarlos a terceros
países solo porque tienen dinero para
influir y hacer cumplir su voluntad sin
embargo las autoridades ruandesas
aseguran que gracias a la financiación
prometida por el reino unido- el
proyecto no supondrá una carga para el
presupuesto gubernamental también
destacan la tradición de hospitalidad
del país desde hace varios años ruanda
participa en asociaciones para
reubicación de refugiados inmigrantes
desde 2019 el país acoge un programa de
acnur que evacua a los migrantes
detenidos en libia y más recientemente
kigali ha recibido refugiados afganos
que huyeron de la toma del país por los
talibanes
a pesar de que desde hace años la unión
europea en su conjunto y algunos estados
miembros por separado externaliza en el
control de fronteras a terceros países
como turquía marruecos o libia reino
unido se convierte en la primera nación
europea en subcontratar a un país del
sur global para la gestión de las
solicitudes de asilo londres sigue así
el ejemplo de australia que a principios
de los años 2000 empezó a enviar a
migrantes al asista a las islas manaus y
naurú una política muy controvertida que
provoca un gran sufrimiento mental y
físico entre los desplazados escuchemos
las declaraciones de daniel soy el
director de la organización de derechos
humanos stand for old
and girls in mind and work y
fundamentalmente es una política
inhumana inviable y muy costosa que ni
siquiera debería ser debatida nunca
debería haberse ni siquiera considerado
cuando se combina con otras políticas
dentro del proyecto de ley de
nacionalidad y fronteras como los
cambios en la evaluación de la edad por
ejemplo estamos hablando de una política
que podría hacer que los niños sean
enviados a un país que queda a 6.400
kilómetros el primer ministro dijo que
esta era una opción humanitaria esta es
la definición de lo contrario al
humanitaria una catástrofe de enormes
proporciones así describió el presidente
sudafricano seguirla ramaphosa la
situación en el este de sudáfrica tras
las terribles inundaciones que azotaron
la provincia de kwazulu-natal
destruyendo casas y dejando a familias
enteras bajo tierra más de 400 personas
han muerto la mayoría de ellas en la
región de durban una de las ciudades
portuarias más importantes del
continente africano situada en la costa
del océano índico
el presidente rama fosa ha prometido
ayudar a las familias de las víctimas
que eran muchos surafricanos y atm en un
desvío de la ayuda por parte de la clase
política y es que los escándalos de
corrupción son numerosos en el país un
ejemplo ha sido la lucha contra el codi
19 que se vio empañada por múltiples
polémicas
mientras el desamparo de la población
hace temer lo peor le preguntamos a omer
freixá historiador africanista cómo
puede afrontar sudáfrica la situación y
si el país corre el riesgo de sufrir
nuevos disturbios como los de julio de
2021 tras la detención del ex presidente
jacob zuma el gobierno ha girado unos
2.000 millones de rancias equivalente a
135 millones de dólares estadounidenses
para hacer frente a este desastre sin
precedentes climáticos y desde ya hay
miedo que se ahorre el dinero por
antecedentes previos de la gestión de la
pandemia de la crisis sanitaria aunque
desde la gobernación aseguraron que a
diferencia cubrirá el pasado esta vez
habría un claro contralor sobre el
destino de estos fondos con lo cual para
no repetir los errores y las malas
gestiones del pasado es muy importante
protagonismo de la zona es que es porque
varias están aportando por ejemplo la
fundación motsepe aportó unos 30
millones de rands equivalente a 2
millones de dólares estadounidenses y
gracias a los escándalos desde vídeo de
fondo durante la crisis sanitaria que se
vivieron estos dos años así precedentes
hay una confianza muy grande en el
público en la sociedad en la ciudadanía
y que el gobierno ha perdido mucha
legitimidad estos últimos dos años no me
parece lejana la convulsión social en la
posibilidad de hecho la semana pasada
hubo protestas y represión de la
remoción de un grupo
desplazado que debía ser reubicado por
la contingencia si bien estaba un grupo
de 100 personas grupos vencido un grupo
pequeño
puede ser botón de muestra algo
en resumen yo diría que el manejo
cuidadoso de la gestión de lo que está
provocando esta terrible crisis
climática y su impacto en la región de
caoba solo natal depende no sólo la paz
social en la región sino en el país
vamos a república democrática del congo
el conflicto protagonizado por decenas
de grupos armados en el este del país se
está cobrando muchas víctimas humanas
pero tampoco perdona a la fauna
silvestre en peligro crítico en el
siguiente reportaje les invitamos a
descubrir el centro de rehabilitación de
simios del bureau el único refugio para
estos animales en el parque nacional de
cajú si llega
6000 kilómetros cuadrados de selva nos
encontramos en el parque qabús y situado
entre dos volcanes extinguidos en el
este de la república democrática del
congo desde su creación en 1970 el
parque ya se ha visto gravemente
afectado por dos guerras civiles que han
asolado el país y ha visto disminuir la
población de animales salvajes
especialmente de grandes simios
afortunadamente el centro de
rehabilitación de primates del wir
situado en las afueras del parque es
ahora un oasis para estos animales
heridos y traumatizados
bertrand llegamos aquí a las 6 30 de la
mañana la vuleta de banana les damos
comida y si hay animales enfermos es
cuando les damos medicinas debemos mala
con profeta leer donde le mentí como la
mayoría de los primates fueron traídos
después de haber sido capturados por
cazadores furtivos que habían abusado de
ellos
dependiendo de la gravedad de sus
heridas un gran simio puede tardar
semanas o meses en recuperarse
ns dmt
intentamos hacer todo lo posible para
ver cómo salvar primero la vida del
animal
si hay heridas o cualquier otro caso
grave podemos ver cómo detener la
hemorragia y luego anestesiar al animal
suturarlo y devolverlo a su jaula animal
es
decir que pone la manera acerca de sus
ojos pero los veterinarios del centro
denuncian la falta de recursos y afable
explicación y con fernando todavía no
hay una implicación del gobierno al 100%
en el cuidado del centro de
rehabilitación de primates de alwin o
imagen de lujo
son los esfuerzos de las personas de
buena voluntad los que intentan
ayudarnos a proteger a los animales que
están muy amenazados
actualmente el centro alberga a más de
100 chimpancés pero también a bonobos y
babuinos desde noviembre de 2020 no se
ha liberado ningún animal en el parque
caius y por la inseguridad sin embargo
los responsables del centro siguen
esperando poder liberarlos algún día en
su hábitat natural
cambiamos de tema para hablar de
deportes el skateboarding sigue siendo
un deporte marginal en áfrica con sólo
10 parques para scripts en todo el
continente y unos pocos entusiastas como
jamón ataca una mujer de 27 años que
multiplica los esfuerzos para atraer
nuevos miembros vamos a ganar para
conocerla
amanece en accra la capital de ghana
mientras harmony ataca patiño con
amplias curvas por una calle de la
ciudad el año pasado esta joven de 27
años dejó su trabajo para dedicarse a
tiempo completo al skateboard su
decisión provocó la consternación de su
entorno ya que este deporte sigue siendo
marginal en áfrica más aún para las
mujeres
me encanta el skate me encanta cada
parte de este deporte y me hace sentir
muy muy bien y me había ahorrado algo de
dinero con mi trabajo así que decidí así
que aunque no tenía ingresos cuando
empecé quería ser libre y hacer lo que
me gustaba tuvo el reloj y en aquel
momento harmony no conocía a ninguna
otra mujer que practicará el skate pero
ahora se encuentra en el centro de una
escena floreciente sobre todo gracias a
la apertura del primer skate park
veganos
una vez a la semana el skatepark está
reservado a las mujeres ya las niñas y
se convierte en el sky del club
estoy muy contenta de que hayan muchas
chicas que quieran intentarlo y me
importa si no quieren continuar y al
menos están dispuestas a intentarlo el
skateboarding es uno de los deportes que
más crece en el mundo pero en el
continente sólo hay unos pocos
skateboard y sólo tres de los 80 skaters
que compitieron en los juegos olímpicos
de toque 2020 eran africanos las mujeres
están poco representadas pero eso podría
cambiar hoy harmony espera que las
sesiones para mujeres animen a las
calesas a lanzarse a practicar este
deporte
el líder sudafricano black coffee solía
denunciar que la música africana está
relegada en un segundo plano pero el
pasado 3 de abril el artista ganó el
premio grammy al mejor álbum electrónico
por su último trabajo psuv con su swing
y se convirtió en el primer africano en
ganar en esa categoría
cerramos esta edición con la música de
black coffee gracias por su sintonía nos
vemos la próxima semana